first of all do you want to respond to
that edit earlier I could feel you
chomping at the bit yeah next time I'm
bringing the earphones for my up for my
iPhone so I don't have to listen to that
without being able to respond well now
you can respond I didn't I forgot we had
this in this internet section so I
stride to pretend I was well I basically
was okay one thing is okay I got the
basic idea 1% of Americans with their
private jets the ones you fly bill
because you're such an environmentalist
I I did when we had debates oh it was
just for me okay for you I don't
understand why anyone who isn't part of
the 40% of America working for state
local or federal government when ever
vote for the Democratic Party since that
is what the Democratic Party stands for
and as I told you interrupting your joke
sorry I couldn't help myself
it's a fact that every juror on the OJ
case was a Democrat everybody blames the
blacks not me I blame the Democrats well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
black night s and Coulter are there any
Obama policies that you support keeping
one-time mouth open maintaining the Bush
tax cuts although I must say I think we
can come together the nation and human
events here I would repeal one part of
the Bush tax cuts and that's the party
you thought was gonna feel to the New
York Times taking all these people off
the tax rolls no everybody should pay
something I don't care if you're sending
in a can of spam you're sending
something in you have no skin in the
game I agree that was a big mistake on
Bush's part okay how will we ever wean
our country off of war if we continue to
glorify it in our National Anthem
Wow well my country tis of thee that's a
very nice him I like that that's yours
yes yeah nice ring to my guess he's
talkin about Francis Scott Key's yeah
glorification of the battle over the
bomb Henry we needed to fight a problem
with that one I mean we needed to fight
that did the British were Pro 1812 I'm
Pro it's exactly as long as I have you
here
what about them are you in favor of us
intervening in these two countries that
didn't hit us on 9/11 for solely for
purposes of regime change first of all I
didn't think we were intervening in
Egypt are we we did what we do what we
do in each we didn't do I mean intervene
or military I mean there's a difference
I mean we talked about it we talked
about it
well we can talk we didn't send any
troops right yeah we're something we're
not dropping the legions
no bombs no Egypt bombs no just Libya
Libya bomb Libya bombs no agent Oh Egypt
bars no yes anyway we were threatening
to which is why Mubarak well no we never
threatened no no no if you're going to
keep going over it would be well I mean
Libya we did for humanitarian reasons I
you know it's funny that let me turn
that back on you when when Obama made
that speech he said something that I
thought if Ronald Reagan had said it you
would have had an orgasm
he said something about how you know
some people can turn a blind eye when
when there's a humanitarian crisis the
United States is different and I thought
wow thank you that made me that made my
nipples hard that's the United States is
different and we are different and
that's what he was doing was stopping
humanitarian crises now at this point
obviously it's a bit of a stalemate sort
of announced reason we were going in was
to stop a massacre in Benghazi the
ground that they'd surrounded we've done
that I mean but now it's extremely
unclear what the mission but also it's
not a United states-led mission I mean
for the first time a United States
president said you know what somebody
else take over for once we are a little
tired and I'm looking at you
don't blame me it was Obama who waited
too long that was the problem
so many weeks went past and then finally
when the bombs did start dropping
Gaddafi was already way underground he'd
already repositioned his troops in his
tanks and now frankly I think it's a
waste of time really you don't think
there's gonna be a good outcome to that
you know I don't I don't know and you
know we don't even know who the
opposition is I mean for all we know
we're bombing the hell out of Gaddafi's
trip so we can let our cut al-qaeda and
the Muslim Brotherhood take over my idea
is to give Qaddafi Afghanistan they need
a strong man he needs a country yes
because because what are we trying to do
in Afghanistan kill rebels that's what
he wants to do
[Laughter]
in light of the recent corporate
friendly Supreme Court decisions is the
u.s. devolving into an oligarchy yeah
yeah I think it is there I want to I
want to plug a book that that's not my
own it's a book called oligarchy it's by
a guy named Jeffrey winters who's a
political scientist it's a book-length
treatment of oligarchy and he has a
chapter on it in the US and it's
extremely persuasive on this on this
point and how would we define all the
turkey well he talks about one of the
things he talks about is looking at he
looks more oligarchs and what oligarchs
do then oligarchy as a system and he
looks at what he calls the income
defense industry which is the the sort
of ways in which those who have you know
the bushel of money you're talking about
in that segment guard it from the hands
of the state ok how long do you think
it'll be before we have an openly gay
president what sometimes things change
faster than you ever expect you know I
mean if somebody had predicted Obama
that a guy named Obama with a new life
that would become president I wasn't
even born here so you just never know
that's right and then look at look at
gay marriage I mean like I said we were
talking about it before only in 2004 it
was a wedge issue the other way it was
like fairly unthinkable right I'm
waiting now for the day when the
president kicked back in the White House
and smoke a joint and be open about it
[Applause]
at some point what did I say
Brianna no I was in the interview with
Ethan Ethan natal man can cooter
[Applause]
no no I said Karl roids no no no Karl
Rove put it on the ballot in key states
course he didn't and in fact Bush came
out in favor of civil unions which was
the identical position to carry the year
2004 however you know who did campaign
against gay marriage yes that's right
Bill Clinton who signed the Defense of
Marriage Act and took out the
Republicans post that is a wedge issue
right to get the gays to not to turn on
on Clinton that was wait so you are do
not meet you I'm sorry I have to talk to
people who we all share the same facts
over and over again yeah we keep called
from the bar to ladies call well not the
same is bombing gone did he take action
shoot for regime change you guys said
you're against Russia no but the way
calling and bombing like I sometimes
I've called you I've never bomb being
backed up by the threat to bomb when I
went Obama says Mubarak has got to go
when the streets are on fire I smell
another book bombing
sir fat that is falling bill clinton ran
ads in black neighborhoods bragging
about signing the Defense of Marriage
Act that is a fact that's not why he was
in black neighborhoods alright we gotta
go thank you very much
[Applause]